how much freedom do members of the lgbtq
community enjoy
well in recent weeks gay pride marches
in countries around the world have
underlied the solidarity in the
community
but discrimination violence and even the
death penalty are still part of the
global agenda
of hate there's been angry criticism of
hungary's new anti-lgbtq law
and of european soccer's blocking of the
use of the movement's rainbow colours
at a big european championship match in
munich
so on the point on to the point we ask
hate against
lgbtq how to tackle exclusion
[Music]
well thanks very much indeed for joining
us here on the show and my guests in the
studio
are joe hutchinson who is a
u.s lawyer and journalist who believes
that
symbolic gestures are a good start but
what really helps the queer community
are meaningful reforms pascal tebow for
radio france international is also with
us he argues that western europe
is tolerant but not quite as tolerant as
it might
think and a very warm welcome too to
bernd reagan dw correspondent in
brussels
he says not only hungary many eastern
european countries
have problems with sexual minorities
thank you for being with me today uh all
three of you and uh
i'd like to go first of all to joe
and uh suggest that there is something
in the air that we've reached a certain
juncture
where there are an awful lot of people
who want to talk about gender inclusion
exclusion all these aspects of
of life yeah suddenly it's top of the
agenda
why um well i think uh my personal
belief is that there's so many other
priorities that governments should be
focused on
um but this is a convenient little way
to distract people so
um hungary this is the second law i
think last year they made it possible
they made it impossible for trans people
to change their genders
from the one they were assigned at birth
this is absolutely a campaign they're
following what russia has done before
them
sexual minorities are a great you know
scapegoat for a lot
of uh social ills and then even in you
know i'd say in germany or in the united
states
um we always see these kind of you know
stoking the culture wars
you know there's it's always a great
thing to pit groups of society against
each other
to distract us frankly from the pressing
needs of you know economic crisis and
climate change what do you say to that
pascal stoking the culture wars
well i think i agree i think it's i mean
it's nothing new that
focal wellness it's very it's a very
easy
politic to use or to misuse
to be right some minorities foreigners
roma people sexual minorities etc
maybe to to develop a debate
to come to focus on on a topic which
maybe
is not the the number one priority in
their country but
so at the same time it avoids maybe to
talk about other topics
which maybe are not less discussions
surrounding uh
developments in hungary for example that
has been a very real political debate
of course yeah and and i mean the the
the politic which mr urban has
implemented in the last years now is
also
also concerned a sexual minority and the
lgbt
iq minority but in the past we also had
several attacks legal attacks so to say
against civil rights so it's also
a new development in something which has
been
developed in the last years and it's
it's also uh it's also we will hear it
maybe it's also
interesting interesting that the
european union has this time
was this time much more faster to react
than
in the past in uh in which what
hungary did okay we will go to ben right
in in
brussels in just a moment tensions there
can be no doubt about it
a running high between the hungarian
government of
victor orban the prime minister and the
european union leaders over the
controversial new law in hungary
widely described as an anti-lgbtq
law here are some impressions of what
has been going on
it was an unusual display of solidarity
before the international match against
hungary
many german fans waved the rainbow flag
representing
their support for the lgbtq community
entire stadiums were also supposed to
shine colorfully in solidarity at the
european championship
but it was prohibited by the uefa
by contrast hungary's fans were almost
aggressive in their support for their
team
which was eliminated from the european
championship
the next day at the eu summit in
brussels victor orban was threatened
with another expulsion
this time from the eu
for me there's nothing for hungary in
the european union but unfortunately in
the system we currently have
i can't do anything on my own about it i
can only force them out with the support
of the other member states
the cause for the outrage the hungarian
parliament plans on banning materials in
school
meant to educate students on
homosexuality
nearly all eu members barring poland and
slovenia consider the law to be a clear
violation of the eu's values such as
freedom from discrimination
consequently it got a little bit lonely
around victor orban at the eu summit
and yet he still sees himself as being
unjustly targeted
so i am defending the rights of the
homosexual guys but this
law is not about that it's about the
right of the kids
and the parents how homophobic is
hungary's new law really
bendrica how homophobic is the law and
do you feel any more comfortable that
that victor orban is now seeing himself
as a champion of homosexuals
well this new law is just the tip of the
iceberg
in hungary there's a tendency to
discriminate more and more against
gays lesbians transgender people
this law shall prevent that
young people get any information about
the sexual minorities
it's meant to to save the family values
um
and this is a long process and mr auburn
maybe himself he's not against gays and
lesbians but he sees
that with this uh kind of policies he he
caters to his audience he's in an
election campaign coming up
and he sees that the society in hungary
actually responds
to this maybe he has the feeling that
that the society wants that and this is
a problem in hungary and in many other
mostly eastern european countries for
example in poland
in bulgaria and romania so there's still
prejudices against
the lgbqi community and
he's using that but he got very harsh
criticism for the first time
the eu commission president said this is
a disgrace
and he was threatened by the dutch prime
minister as we heard
and also the luxembourgish prime
minister xavier battle who's
gay himself was very personal and said
that auburn understood nothing
about the gay and lesbian community
but it didn't impress him i guess the
law is still in place in hungary and now
the commission has to sue
hungary in luxembourg at the european
court so this is still a long way to go
and it's all a political mess here in
brussels it's interesting that you
mentioned there savior battle the
the prime minister of luxembourg his
comments were very
uh very much his own
they were very much they were not just
policy statements they were emotions
can you tell us he was very he was very
personal he
he told the 26 other
heads of state and governments in
brussels about his
own coming out about his the fights with
his mother
uh she didn't understand uh that he's
gay and and stuff like that and he said
it's if hungary and if orban is pursuing
this kind of policy he
personally feels touched and threatened
and there was a very loud discussion
and only the polish and the slovenian
prime minister
on the side of hungary and all others
said battle
is right of course that you cannot do
this in in europe
uh in the 21st century that that has to
stop
and the the past should be in the other
direction not going
back rolling back the rights of gays and
lesbians but
the other way around uh pascal what do
you make of these comments from the
dutch prime minister mark rutter saying
that there is no place for hungary
in the eu we will see if it's
only a sentence or if it if we will have
some consequences i that we all know
that it's uh
almost impossible to get rid of a
country and to exclude
this country from the european union
it's very difficult also to
agree on on sanctions against a country
so um i prefer to wait if there will
be consequences but it's sure that these
values and some other ones are the
ground principles of or should be the
ground principles of our
modern european civilization and uh
it's but it's uh of course it's for
people like
like urban but other other ones in in
poland and elsewhere
it's of course a wonderful topic to
uh because it's linked to identity and
so
you can with such a topic uh
increase the fear of the mat of a lot of
people in the in the population of a lot
of heterosexual people
especially if they are more conservative
who have the impression
their own identity will be questioned we
had the same debate with
huge demonstration nine years ago in
france when the the the
heterosexual marriage was opened a lot
of people a lot of friends in germany
told me
how is it possible in france at the
beginning of the 21st century
because these people think a new law
for a minority will take them some
rights they always have but it's not
about that
it's about giving some rights to people
who
didn't have them that's a difference joe
yes i think um what we see time and time
again is
um and i don't want to just i know
things are difficult in eastern europe
but i don't want to look
to pretend as if the problem is only in
eastern europe and so when i see
people like makota and i know he's
probably well intentioned but we need to
look at what can we change
you know from at a societal level
because depending on where you go it's
not that we always have
or i always experience the same rights
and privileges no matter where i go
um you know living in berlin i do not
walk around
the streets holding my partner's hand
because i don't feel safe here
to do that you don't do that full stop
absolutely not no i will not do that
because i have to constantly be
scrutinizing are we going to be
personally attacked verbally or
physically
that's happening and so while i
understand
we should apply pressure on countries
like hungary i think there are other
ways to do it i think
at a super national level so you know
the european leaders talking to
themselves
i think business leaders could threaten
you know to pull their factories out of
hungary
if they don't get in line with what
european values are i think that's the
proper way to do it
but not to assume that it's only in
hungary where queer people are under
attack
well tell us what tell us tell us about
where else uh you're aware of
you know similar levels of of threat
around europe or anywhere else well so
it definitely uh so you know speaking
from my personal
opinion um there's certain places where
i feel more comfortable
and for various reasons so again it's
not it's generally for me not a country
it's you know i might feel safer in an
urban center than i would um in the
countryside somewhere
because of various aspects of how i'm
going to be perceived
and how hostile potentially people are
going to be to me so
i think when we're talking about you
know the rights of sexual minorities
thank you for also mentioning you know
like
racial minorities ethnic minorities um
there's a whole
tapestry of uh you know we have you know
europe's
uh heritage is that it's all very varied
and different but i think we're also
seeing now there
there isn't one um uniform european
experience it really depends on a
day-to-day basis you know
where are you and how are you moving
through society ben in this discussion
between
between brussels and hungary
what is likely to happen next where is
that discussion likely to go
well the commission will open up an
infringement procedure against hungary
this is the formal step and then
take hungary to the courts but
the commission is also trying to
convince hungary with
a threat and that's about money because
the disbursement of funds from the next
eu budget is linked
to a state of law mechanism it's called
and this could be
used for the first time in this case but
this is still
a way to go because every all member
states
have to agree and poland and slovenia
are on the side of hungary so it's still
complicated
but i also wanted to say that even in
countries like belgium
here in brussels you are not always as
safe as a gay man you can of course hold
the hand of your
of your partner in the european quarter
but if you go downtown
where the muslim communities the migrant
communities live there it's
very advisable not to do that so they
are also problem in in
western europe and it's it's a societal
problem it's not only politics because
the rights
in belgium in the books are perfect for
gays
belgium is ranking on the second place
in a list
that the rainbow and lobby groups do
every year
malta is the first place in europe
belgium ii
so but there are still problems pascal
tell me about what you
what we know about the situation of
young members of the lgbtq community
these days
somebody let's say in their early 20s
looking to sort of design their the
the life they have ahead of them or they
want to have out of them
is that now easier than than it used to
be let's say 20 years ago
or do the same kinds of problems that
have always been there remain
i would say generally speaking the
situation
has improved positively
we have more legal rights there are more
organizations
which are active you have more places
which can offer
a certain protection uh or
give you advice especially in in bigger
cities
but on the other hand it depends where
you live
it will be of course much more difficult
if you live in a little
czech village on a little hungarian
village
where you have a very conservative
population
it depends also what's your background
uh
of course if you leave if you if your
parents came from turkey or syrian are
very religious muslim it will be
probably
much more difficult to have your coming
out or
especially to be accepted through your
uh through your
parents and we don't want to to don't
want to talk about somebody coming from
that minority
wanted to uh wanted to change
uh to change and to become a trans man
or a trans woman
so that's you have very very different
situations very different constellations
as we already uh
as as it was already said we live here
in berlin
although there are still problems you
have homophobic attacks every week
but we we live here in a certain bubble
and this bubble uh with
its limits uh of course doesn't exist uh
in a lot of places and also uh
for uh for certain certain young people
uh who had different different
background
different religious background or
different parents so i think it's it's
it can still be difficult the the
average suicide rate amongst
teenagers is higher among lgbtq
iq people than in the average
population for example so you still have
problem you still have
dramatic situations but on the other
hand in big cities like in berlin or
elsewhere in paris in in amsterdam
i think for these young people for
example the necessity to
to go out in a in queer places
uh today to go to a dance club which is
uh which is definitely gay or lesbian or
whatever
that's not a necessity nowadays because
you can
be yourself wherever you are in certain
big cities
in certain areas joe a word on that
before we move on to the broader
perspective
yes i think what we have to understand
is um the queer community is not
uniform so while it may be easier for
some people
we have to recognize it's still about
survival it's still about
you know visibly queer people are going
to be subject to violence no matter
where they go and i want to push back on
this you know
not just in migrant neighborhoods you
know i'm when i'm talking about i don't
feel comfortable in berlin i also mean
in berlin mitta
um so we have to understand that if you
are visibly queer if you are breaking
the norms
um it's just going to depend and it's
going to shift throughout the day how
comfortable you're going to feeling
i would agree that younger people are
generally growing up with
more role models with more of visibility
with more awareness
so i think you know um it's not as
difficult to at least find the
information once they may suspect that
they are different from their peers
and i you know i see various groups of
young people where
sexuality gender it's kind of more
amorphous but again that depends on the
bubble you're looking at and if they can
find the community
okay well homosexuals in many countries
around the world live in the fear of
violence
arrest and even the death penalty that
includes many muslim countries like
chechnya somalia
iran and saudi arabia before we talk
about that
shocking threat let's have a look at
some other examples
ronnie khan runs pakistan's first
madrasa for transgender
people she also teaches them how to sew
so that they can sell clothes to pay for
their gender affirmation treatment along
the way
most families do not accept transgender
people they throw them out of their
homes
they turn to wrongdoing they start
dancing and begging and doing other evil
things
i was one of them khan hopes to unite
transgender people by using islam
in pakistan alone there are an estimated
300 000 transgender people
and for these students the madrasa is
not only a stepping stone for greater
acceptance within society
it also serves as a safe haven for them
because in many muslim countries like
here in senegal there is still
tremendous prejudice against the lgbti
community
as this demonstration against equal
rights for homosexuals
clearly indicates
on the other hand during tunisia's last
presidential election in 2019
maunier batur a member of the lgbt
rights organization
shams even ran for the country's highest
office
is there light at the end of the rainbow
worldwide
[Music]
calls are often made to our governments
and to brussels to do something about
the situation about the climate of
hatred
that i alluded to earlier band what what
can
brussels do well of course there are
official policies in place
to promote european values which is
non-discrimination of sexual minorities
um and even in europe this is difficult
as we heard and to transport this into
the
wider world it's even more difficult
because
the influence the eu has on for example
saudi arabia or african countries to
change
these laws or this societal behavior is
of course
limited and if you have countries like
hungary in your midst
that are not obeying to this these
values it's even more difficult to
to have your stand in the world so it's
it's a well it's a long way to go still
i'm just trying to mesh this a little
bit together to i'd like to come back to
budapest to hungary where
there's there's a big debate about the
clash of cultures in hungarian society
in eastern european society liberal
societies
against illiberal societies who would
want to live in a liberal society what's
the understanding from brussels of that
conundrum
well if you look at hungary or poland
for example
the parties that are promoting this
ill-liberal
democracy are still winning elections so
you have to see
that it seems that a majority of people
still is supporting this
and we now see especially in hungary
discussion
because of the upcoming elections that
this might change because all opposition
parties are now
putting together a list to to beat the
fidesh party of
mr orban but it's still a struggle and
it's it's in the structures
of the societies in eastern europe that
they are not as far
advanced when it comes to to civil
rights and
gay rights and lesbian rights this is
the matter of the truth it can change
but it will take time
what do you say about that pascal that
we have we have to for for
a period of time accept that there is
prejudice that there is hatred
yeah unfortunately yes and i think uh
what
uh what we have to what we can see
in these examples in in hungary right
now
in poland where conservative people
proclaim these so-called lgbt-free zones
the situation in romania is also very
problematic
it shows that there is not a logical
positive development in the in the
history
with always every year or
with always new and more rights for lgbt
people you can also have a rollback
uh i mean the situation since the end of
the communism
was never perfect in in hungary and
poland and is in these other countries
but
in poland for example you have you still
have but
you had uh pride marches etc
and there were some some positive
developments and now we have this roll
back
we also have it in a certain form also
in france for example where you you you
see that on
values we have a society which is
more conservative than it was i think
some years ago
uh so um yeah so that's why
it's important to yeah not to stop the
the struggle
and to fight uh every day for us
for our neighbors and also outside from
europe
joe you come you come from the country
that gave us you know women's with the
women's rights movement in large measure
in the 60s black rights
and gay rights is how how great is your
fear that
uh instead of progress being made we now
maybe face
a backlash at least in some respects um
well i think it's very important to
realize as pascal said that there's
always going to be pushback it's never
so there's this
mistaken belief that we're always going
to have progress that's unending and
nothing can hold us back
it's a push and pull um because as
people get more uncomfortable there's
going to be reactionary pushback
and so we as a society are evolving and
that involves you know being
recognizing that it's going to go in
this direction going in the dark
direction you know the united states
just
survived four years of donald trump um
and so we can really see how even
in as stable democracy as we like to
call it the united states
we're also encountering these issues
with you know liberalism and
authoritarianism
but something i think i just want to
point out is you know as
as valiant as it is to want to influence
other countries
we should also focus on what can
european countries that are have a
problem with orban what can they do in
their own
homes okay i hear the music now we don't
have time
we we have been talking about how best
to tackle exclusion i really would like
to have had that in a nutshell
burnt how to tackle exclusion what do we
do
well you have to try harder
in the future good we'll tell you that
there's good advice coming from brussels
we've been talking about
the lgbtq community and how to tackle
exclusion thanks very much for joining
us
see you next time around cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you